[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue
édition spéciale ici sur France 24 notre
invité est l'ancien président ukrainien
monsieur porochenko il est avec nous en
direct
des rues de Kiev merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est un plaisir merci
beaucoup pour soutenir l'Ukraine et
d'apporter les vérités sur les éléments
de qui est fait en Ukraine pour ma
nation exactement alors où êtes-vous
exactement et quelle est la situation à
Kief là où vous êtes à l'heure actuelle
je suis dans le centre de Kiev
à peu près 800 mètres du siège du
gouvernement et environ 4 km de trop
Prusse en ce moment même vous voyez nous
avons une alerte de raid aérien à cause
des bombardiers russes
et vous savez que aujourd'hui
le 24 février
c'est aujourd'hui donc le 5e jour de
l'agression et tous ces jours nous avons
des missiles russes lancé depuis la
Belarus et depuis la Russie
et nous avons un scandale il y a eu un
dread aérien
qui a frappé l'Ukraine et les civils et
malheureusement
il y a déjà environ 500 6000 qui ont été
tués au cours de ces cinq jours
est-ce que vous êtes obligé de dormir
dans un refuge comme la plupart des
habitants de la capitale non
je reste dans le bureau de mon parti en
fait l'ancien bureau de mon parti qui
est maintenant le quartier général du
bataillon de la défense territoriale
j'organise ce bataillon et aujourd'hui
il y a énormément
d'habitants de Kiev des gens
tranquilles qui ont décidé de protéger
notre nation mais je veux remercier le
soutien occidental croissant
apporté à l'Ukraine dans ces moments
très difficiles peut-être les plus
difficiles de notre histoire
ça s'est produit dès les premiers jours
et
de l'invasion
et le soutien fort est en train de
stopper j'espère
la tentative de Poutine de déclencher la
troisième guerre mondiale et nous
montrant que nous n'avons pas peur de
Poutine nous faisons pas confiance en
Poutine Poutine il est faible quand nous
sommes ensemble c'est la grande chance
de prouver que quand nous sommes unis
quand on est prêt à faire des sanctions
quand on est prêt à être présent c'est
extrêmement important et je remercie ici
un très bon ami de l'Ukraine et un très
bon ami à moi le président de la
République Macron le chancelier Schultz
et tous les dirigeants de l'Union
européenne qui ont pris une décision
très importante hier qui était
donné par
Ursula vanderline qui pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'Union
européenne
décision prise de payer de livrer à
l'Ukraine des armes létales qui peuvent
arrêter l'agresseur et peuvent augmenter
le prix payé par Poutine et par la
Russie pour envahir l'Ukraine Poutine
parce que Poutine a lancé une agression
non seulement contre l'Ukraine Poutine a
lancé une agression contre l'Union
européenne contre la France et contre
l'ensemble du monde civilisé et nous ici
nous payons peut-être le prix le plus
lourd mais nous protégeons aussi la
liberté la démocratie car la seule chose
qui ne fasse souffrir c'est que c'est
parce que nous voulons être libre nous
voulons revenir dans la famille
européenne et c'est la raison pour
laquelle Poutine nous déteste
est-ce que vous êtes surpris monsieur
prochain que vous avez été président
pendant plusieurs années vous avez
demandé un appui européen
très rapidement il y a eu des sanctions
assez fortes et maintenant il y a même
des armes qui vont être envoyés le chef
de la diplomatie européenne a même
mentionné des chasseurs c'est beaucoup
en quelques jours non
je suis pas surpris
je suis fier que mon équipe et moi
nous ayons ancré l'armée ukrainienne
crée la possibilité de défendre et de
frapper le groupe de Poutine nous
montrons en faisons la preuve que
l'Ukraine a une des armées les plus
fortes d'Europe et c'est en passant
pourquoi est absolument nécessaire de
présenter la le plan d'action de
l'Ukraine à l'OTAN parce que
ce sera mutuellement bénéfique parce que
avec nous avec l'Ukraine l'autense
serait plus fort et est extrêmement
important au moins que c'est pour la
première fois dans l'histoire que il y a
eu cette décision de fournir à l'armée
de l'air ukrainienne des avions imaginez
que 52 chasseurs et hélicoptères de la
Russie ont été touchés et
mis au sol par l'Armée de l'Air
ukrainienne par des missiles Anta aérien
nous avons absolument besoin de ces
missiles nous avons absolument besoin de
ces avions parce que demain si on n'est
pas équipé en Ukraine ces avions
apparaîtront dans n'importe quelle
nation européenne et c'est pour ça que
nous avons besoin d'une zone d'exclusion
aérienne en Ukraine
parce que
l'Ukraine est une nation souveraine et
nous avons le droit
d'interdire l'entrée dans notre espace
aérien et ce serait l'une des mesures
les plus efficaces
pour la sécurité de l'Europe et nous
avons absolument besoin d'autres mesures
nous attendons encore et nous nous
réjouissons la décision prise hier par
le Conseil de l'Union européenne par
nous avons absolument besoin de
confirmer
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne du Canada de GP et un prix
énorme rien que pour avoir la
possibilité d'être européenne et nous
avons absolument besoin que le statut de
candidat soit présenté
par l'Ukraine maintenant
c'est une motivation forte d'être unie
d'être forte d'être de coopérer avec
l'Union européenne nous avons besoin
absolument maintenant et de lancer une
processus d'adhésion sans aucun retard
c'est la bonne réponse à Poutine qui ne
peut pas nous empêcher de revenir à la
famille européenne et puis nous avons
absolument besoin
de nous aider à nous rétablir pour que
l'Ukraine se rétablisse nous sommes dans
une situation extrêmement difficile
actuellement
nous avons des plantes très claires et
actuellement vous savez dans 20 minutes
de je serai au parlement
ukrainien je rencontrerai tous les
membres du Parlement et je vais
immédiatement lancer la demande
d'adhésion à l'Union européenne et nous
avons
avec la même décision qui a été démontré
hier pour les armes létales et pour le
soutien militaire de l'Ukraine ce sera
démontré à tous les autres États membres
parce qu'ils ont dit publiquement qu'il
soutenaient l'Ukraine et dans cette
situation je pense que
l'Ukraine démontre ce que signifie
frapper la Russie parce que Poutine
s'attendait à ce que l'Ukraine rencontre
les troupes russes avec des fleurs et au
lieu des fleurs nous les avons
rencontrés avec des cocktails Molotov
beaucoup de transports de troupes
ont été frappés
le nombre de Russes qui ont été tués au
cours des cinq derniers jours
dépassent les 5000 c'est plus quand
Tchétchénie c'est plus que dans toutes
les autres guerres de la Russie plus
qu'en Syrie ou ailleurs était ainsi que
nous devons arrêter ensemble la Russie
mais nous voulons la paix
Mr presse monsieur le Président en
parlant de paix normalement des
négociations devraient avoir lieu
aujourd'hui entre une délégation russe
et une délégation
ukrainienne
espérez-vous que cela mène à un cesser
le feu ou êtes-vous sceptique sur le
fait que cela va mener à une quelconque
solution temporaire
écoutez au cours de cinq années j'ai
négocié beaucoup avec la Russie avec
Poutine et très souvent nous sommes
parvenus un résultat
nous n'avons besoin de rien
d'extraordinaire
nous pensons à des choses très simples
nous avons besoin d'un cesser le feu et
deuxièmement nous ne voulons aucun
compromis sur l'intégrité territoriale
et l'indépendance de l'Ukraine
nous avons une demande très simple que
les Russes quittent l'Ukraine
tout le reste on peut en discuter
pensez-vous que Monsieur Poutine est
prêt à le faire il se rende compte qui
est là peut-être mal calculé les choses
pensez-vous qu'il va essayer de
d'exercer une pression supplémentaire
militairement je pense qu'il a fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'erreurs tout d'abord
il a sous-estimé la capacité de défense
de la nouvelle armée ukrainienne qui a
été créé par les Ukrainiens parce que
les Ukrainiens sont unis les Ukrainiens
ne sont pas démoralisés les Ukrainiens
sont prêts à se battre et Poutine
s'attendait à une guerre éclair Poutine
un même préparé un communiqué de presse
du deuxième jour
en pensant qu'ils allaient prendre Kiev
qu'ils entreraient que supprimeraient le
gouvernement ukrainien
et on leur a donné aucune chance ils ont
déjà payé un prix très très fort et
ensuite il ne s'attendait pas à ce que
la solidarité avec l'Ukraine avec les
Ukrainiens soit si forte et que
nos partenaires occidentaux puissent
faire preuve d'une telle unité en
présentant des sanctions et les
sanctions sont en train de détruire
complètement l'économie russe
à donner à la possibilité à chaque russe
qui soutient le meurtre des Ukrainiens
de sentir dans sa propre poche qui se
passe parce que le rouble la devise
russe a été dévalué déjà deux fois de 50
%, ce qui signifie que les Russes
commencent à être deux fois plus pauvres
et ce n'est qu'un début
l'économie russe peut s'effondrer
les Russes commencent à
manifester contre Poutine Poutine n'a
pas d'autre choix
s'il veut garder son pays il doit
retirer
ces troupes faire un cesser le feu et
avoir des négociations pour la sécurité
de la Russie nous on a rien à voir avec
la Russie nous n'avons jamais voulu
l'attaquer et tout ce qu'on veut faire
c'est simplement la paix arrêter la
guerre
faire reculer les troupes russes du
crâne et aujourd'hui
je pense que le monde entier est avec
nous et je veux profiter de cette
occasion pour remercier le peuple
français
je remercie le gouvernement français
remercier le président Macron et le
président Hollande aussi qui entre les
deux coopérer étroitement avec moi et je
veux remercier chaque personne
qui a participé aux manifestations à
Paris en soutien de l'Ukraine
je vais remercier la diaspora à Paris
d'avoir été tellement forte d'avoir
démontré une telle solidarité vous êtes
super nous sommes ensemble nous sommes
forts et nous allons nous battre contre
cette agresseurs
merci beaucoup monsieur pourchenko
d'avoir pris de votre temps
depuis les rues de Kiev et merci
d'avoir écouté cet entretien exclusif
notre couverture des événements de la
guerre en Ukraine continue ici sur
France 24
[Musique]